at the fastest rate in 40 years and the
pressure on families means pressure on
the government and specifically on the
man who's just been speaking on the
treasury he has now made it clear he
will cut taxes in the autumn for
businesses and other action is likely
much sooner we stand ready to do more he
said
meanwhile the round between the uk and
the eu over changes to the northern
ireland protocol rumbles on and could of
course for some time yet all that as
dark clouds gather over parliament once
again with the news that a conservative
mp has been arrested and released on
bail on suspicion of rape
so lots to talk about this evening as we
bring you takes from all sides over the
next 60 minutes
situation evolves our response will
evolve
i have always been clear we stand ready
to do more
well that was the chancellor in just in
the last few minutes promising once
again he is ready to do more on that
cost of living crisis and it seems like
he might have to soon because of
exchanges like this
he doesn't actually understand what
working families are going through in
this country nothing could be more
transparent from this exchange than
their lust to raise taxes on business
mrs
we don't
we don't relish it
we don't want to do it
well the prime minister and the leader
of the opposition clashed repeatedly
over the main topic of the week we're
actually really the main topic of the
year we'll discuss what the government
might do next
and of course no one better to ask than
our viewers as everyone of course faces
the challenge of rapidly rising prices
we'll see what our panel uh make of it
all uh we can see almost everyone there
one empty chair but hopefully everyone
will be there in just a few moments of
time give us a quick wave
looking forward to speaking to you all
later
there we'll also have some top guests on
the programme tonight including the
attorney general zweller braverman plus
labour's shadow education secretary
bridget phillipson and much more besides
that's all coming up on the take
[Music]
good evening well one topic dominates
politics and probably most of our lives
at the minute and that of course is the
cost of living crisis
inflation hitting nine percent today was
a stark reminder of how bad it is and
it's going higher yet it was top of the
agenda at prime minister's questions
today and it's also clear the government
feels it is gonna have to act and soon
we now have confirmation from the
chancellor he is going to cut taxes for
business in the autumn budget and it
sounds like there is other action to
come for the rest of us as well
meanwhile the row over the northern
ireland protocol isn't going away either
and on this program we're also not going
to stop asking the questions about
behaviour in parliament and the conduct
of mps let's have a look at the week so
far
another sex scandal is about to rock
westminster scotland yard have confirmed
to sky news that an mp has been arrested
and remains in custody following a
number of sex allegations conservative
whips have confirmed to sky news it is a
conservative mp if it is believed a
crime has been committed please go
directly to the police
while the war in eastern europe
continues so too detentions over trade
closer to home as the prime minister
prepares to scrap parts of the uk brexit
deal we would love this to be done in a
consensual way
with our friends and partners uh
ironing out the problems uh stopping
some of these these barriers east-west
but to get that done to have the
insurance we need to we need to proceed
with a legislative solution at the same
time in the mother of all parliaments as
it boasts that there would be an attempt
to legislate to break international law
is shocking it's breathtaking and i we
find ourselves astounded the government
is under pressure to try and give people
more help to cope with rising energy
bills soaring inflation and tax rises
one of the obstacles is about being able
to take on more hours or even move to a
better paid job and of course um it's an
individual situation depending on on
that particular family situation when
would he stop the hokey kokee and just
back labour's plan for a windfall tax to
cut household bills
[Applause]
because labour's plans are always and
everywhere to raise taxes on business we
will look uh we will look at measures
and we will look at all the measures
that we need to take uh mr speaker to
get people through to the other side is
he for it
is he against it
or is he sitting on the fence like his
chancellor i just remind the house the
right honourable gentleman struggled uh
to define what a woman was uh
he couldn't he couldn't if he couldn't
make up his mind on that point uh mr
speaker uh heaven help us
well with the chancellor just sitting
down after his comments to the cbi let's
get some reaction now from the
government uh straight away shall we we
can speak now to the attorney general
zweller braveman who's live in the
palace of westminster thank you very
much for being with us this evening
um we just heard from the chancellor
rishi sunak he said we have a collective
responsibility to help the most
vulnerable we stand ready to do more
what are you going to do
well
the government has already acted whilst
we accept times are tough for many
households around the country because of
inflation caused largely because of
factors outside our control i must add
you know we're seeing similar trends in
the us and the eu
it's right the government should act and
that's why we've already
announced a 22 billion pound package of
support to help people particularly
those on the lowest incomes with the
cost of living and much of that is
phased out across the year so whether
it's raising the national living wage
whether it's helping families with their
energy bills through the 150 pound
council tax rebate that will set is set
to increase later this year or whether
it's the biggest ever cut in fuel duty
uh and there are many other measures
that we've already announced which are
already taking effect which are designed
specifically to help all of those people
struggling right now with the cost of
living um you're talking there about
what's already been announced um but
rishi sunett was pretty clear there that
he's signaling that more is to come he
said our response will evolve we stand
ready to do more and i guess my question
is you know lots of families are going
to be really really worried about how
they're going to make ends meet we've
seen these inflation figures nine
percent the biggest rise in 40 years he
was pretty clear to the businesses
what's going to happen he said in the
autumn budget we will cut your taxes why
can't you be clear to families and and
working people and people who are really
struggling up and down the country why
can't you be clear to ordinary people as
well what are you actually going to do
well i think we have been very clear and
we've actually taken action in november
almost two million of the lowest income
working households who receive universal
credit will have been benefiting from a
cash boost worth a thousand pounds on
average and that's thanks to our
reduction to the universal credit taper
rate and an increase to claimants work
allowances we've been clear uh about the
150 pound council tax rebate to support
people with their energy bills we've
been clear we're doubling the household
support fund with an extra 500 million
pounds available to help directly those
people most in need so i think we've
actually been quite clear there is a lot
of support there and of course the
chancellor is right we're always going
to be keeping a watching brief on the
situation and we'll respond as things
evolve well just to jump in because
you're saying the chancellor wants to
keep a watching eye on the situation and
that's really what i'm asking about i
know i understand the stuff that's been
announced already but i think what is
clear is the chancellor and i think many
of your own mps are conceding that you
are going to take further action our
response will evolve we stand ready to
do more and my question is what what is
that more what are you going to do
well that is a decision for the
chancellor in terms of how he announces
that
but i'm very pleased with what we've
heard uh this evening and i'm just
hearing it second hand on reports in the
media that he wants to cut taxes as
conservatives we instinctively want to
keep taxation low we trust individuals
and people to spend their money better
than government ultimately that's the
big difference between us and the labour
party and we want to ensure that
taxation
is low and that's why from july of this
year we are increasing the national
insurance thresholds to save a typical
worker 330 pounds a year with 70 of
employees
that are going to be coming into effect
i understand you know the conservative
principle that you know a marginal pound
is is better spent by an individual than
the state i get that but we are in
extraordinary times here inflation is at
nine percent there's a lot of people on
benefits who are worried about keeping
their children warm about putting food
on the table so actually for them
perhaps that marginal pound spent by the
state is is the difference between
keeping their families warm and not or
getting an extra loaf of bread at the
weekend right
do they move what natural rules apply
as i said at the outset we're very much
aware that many families will be
struggling right now and particularly
for those people on benefits there are a
huge amount of resources available to
them for example if you look at an
average household in the outgoings it's
things like their bills their utility
bills that's why i won't mention it a
third time but help on council tax but
for people on benefits it goes even
further there is help to assist on water
bills there's help to assist um on
paying child care that's not just
available for people on benefits that's
actually available to a very wide number
of people and actually there's many
people thousands of households who are
not actually claiming the 15 or 13 at
the same time though hours free child
care paid for by the government there's
help to help credit is going up by 3.7
universal credits going up by 3.7
inflation is going up today by nine
percent i mean i'm not a mathematician
but you know and i know that things are
getting very very hard for families and
actually just saying actually look
there's loads of help around there
people just need to look a bit harder to
find it is that really
sufficient
listen i i as i say we are very
cognizant of the struggles that many
families are facing however i just want
to say it's not fair to say that the
government has done nothing and that
we're somehow not responding okay we've
announced a 22 billion pound package
that's significant we've announced
significant tax cuts um
what when do you think more help as
rishi sunak signaled when will that come
will that come in july before the summer
recess
listen you're you're asking me something
that really is going to be a decision
for the chancellor and the prime
minister and then the cabinet he's made
an announcement today that's going to be
worked through and in terms of uh how
that's announced um but i can't give you
any timelines on announcements but if if
the chancellor says there will be tax
cuts coming i trust i trust him and i'm
very glad to hear it okay now you of
course are the attorney general you're
the legal advisor to the government
if the uk government unilaterally scraps
or
ignores parts of the northern ireland
protocol without the agreement of the eu
with of course whom you signed the uh
brexit deal with would that be breaking
the law
i can't get into the details of legal
advice unfortunately i know that might
sound a bit odd but there's a convention
in government which means that the law
officers can't comment on the fact or
the content of their legal advice but
we do know uh what the foreign secretary
has said and she has made very clear in
her statement yesterday that the action
proposed by the government has a lawful
basis and there will be a statement
which will be issued by the government
in due course setting out a bit more
detail behind that so i'm not able to go
into the details behind the legalities
what i am able to say is that the
measures announced are important vital
and have my support it's really uh
there's there are challenges and
problems in northern ireland caused by
the operation of the protocol uh in
relation to uh i mean and the effects of
those problems are visible for everyone
to see we've seen the collapse of
stormont so that people in northern
ireland are not going to be getting the
services that they deserve because of a
paralysis in their government we've seen
um more uh
burdens and costs uh imposed on traders
based in northern ireland because of
excessive uh bureaucracy uh you know
affected by the eu's application of the
rules in the protocol so there are
problems uh we want to get stormont back
up and running we want to ensure that uh
northern ireland's place in within the
uh territory of the united kingdom is
secured and reassured and that's why
these proposals are very important
i just want to ask a really sort of
simple uh question and you know you're
saying that there's a convention not to
publish the uh legal advice but at the
same time we are in uh quite an
extraordinary situation uh the situation
of course in northern ireland uh
extremely uh um you know
fragile very lots of people are very
very concerned about what's happening
there will you commit to publishing
the legal advice on this
the foreign secretaries make clear that
we're going to be publishing a statement
so that's a bit different though isn't
it so just can we just unpick that bit
will you publish the legal advice that
you gave to the government or are we
just going to rely on on a statement
what will be in that statement
what's actually happening no we're not
going to publish the legal advice it's
incredibly rare
for the government to publish its legal
advice i don't think it's actually uh
ever really been done before so if that
there are you know any lawyer will know
uh legal advice is privileged and
confidential that uh means even more in
the context of government and uh you
know this is an important issue and uh
you know the government has the right to
keep its uh legal advice private and
confidential i hope you'd respect that
anybody else has that right but i think
that what the government is doing as i
said it will be setting out a bit more
detail about the legal basis so that
people have a bit more of an
understanding about why we think the
action taken is lawful i just want to
try to work out your red lines on what's
happening at the minute with the
protocol because you know talking to
some people on the eu side they say look
we're willing to try and find a landing
zone where there's fewer checks needed
do you want to see the role of the
european court of justice removed in
ruling and disputes in northern ireland
yes
the european court of justice should not
be the final arbiter of disputes between
the uk and the eu and the bill that we
have committed to introducing will
reflect that
there's no way there's no way that
you're going to get an agreement with
the eu on this is there frankly if if
that is a red line for you
well i i've i've been talking about uh
issues relating to the european union
for many for too many years now to know
that uh those in the media who predict
uh the worse aren't often uh proven to
be right sophie with respect so i i
wouldn't want to prejudge the outcome of
what happens with these uh with this
issue i very much hope the eu will uh
respond uh creatively uh positively
constructively the ideal outcome for all
of us is that we get a renegotiated
settlement that works for the united
kingdom and in particular works for the
uh the northern ira the communities in
northern ireland and upholds the primacy
of the good friday agreement the
foundation ease but also respects the uh
the the boundaries of the european union
single market which the uk really does
pay a lot of respect to okay and very
just just quickly because i do want to
talk to you about one other topic as
well but you know some people listening
to you will find this frankly quite
astonishing uh that the uk is willing to
unilaterally effectively rip up major
parts of an agreement that you signed
that people said would lead to uh checks
along the rsc that boris johnson sold as
a brilliant deal and now you're just
saying that actually no we can just
unilaterally rip the whole thing up
and it's not such a great deal after all
what is going on
i think what most people will find very
astonishing uh
more worryingly actually is how the
situation in northern ireland has been
detrimentally affected by the eu's
application of the protocol we ended 54
of the 19 members of the northern
ireland assembly are in favor of keeping
the um protocol as it is rather than
scrapping it
well well you'll know well actually
the majority all parties actually agree
that there are profound problems with
the protocol so that's actually not
controversial
and the majority the largest group on
the executive the unionists all agree
that the protocol must be changed
fundamentally so i don't think you know
i think the people in northern ireland
54 the 90 members of the northern
ireland assembly are
from parties who are in favor of not
doing what you want to do with the
protocol but in effectively maintaining
it
well what we know is that in northern
ireland uh because of the eu's
application of the protocol we are
seeing onerous checks and costs being
applied to traders the the chairman of
marks and spencers has come out and said
that the way it's being implemented is
is is bureaucratic it's making it's very
difficult for making it's almost making
it's making it almost impossible for
business to be done
and that actually the disproportionate
level of checks uh just doesn't really
isn't justifiable and that's what we
want to remedy we want to find a
compromise and we want to definitely
find uh an agreement that works as i say
for northern ireland for all communities
for both communities and for the eu and
for the uk
now we have seen more allegations and
some allegations about a conservative
mp arrested on suspicion of rape now he
hasn't been named
now previously it was quite common for
you know suspects to be named after an
arrest that that seems to have changed
more recently on privacy concerns unless
there's a strong public interest to name
them
do you think it's right that the mp
should not be named at this point
well first of all i think it is
obviously
shocking and worrying that we've had
this report i have to i don't know that
many details only know as much as i'm
hearing on the media and i don't know
who it is importantly but what we do
know is that someone has been arrested
and i think the reason uh this person
has been asked to stay away from
parliamentary estate i think that's a an
important step forward however
i think that if the moment if the whip
is removed at this stage it then becomes
obvious who this person is um and um
that will also potentially prejudice the
anonymity of the victim who may at this
stage still want to remain uh anonymous
so i think that we're at a very delicate
stage and i think steps need to be taken
very carefully and of course you know uh
at the right time and in the right
circumstances uh a person may be named
but i think right now it's premature
okay now just to ask very briefly to end
about the wider culture at westminster
and to be clean i'm not talking i'm
talking in general i'm not talking about
the specific case
is there a misogyny problem at
westminster and if there is what needs
to change
honestly and speaking uh based on my own
experience no
um i have been in parliament now as an
mp for seven years i've been in politics
for almost 20 years it is uh male
dominated that's true but is there a
culture of misogyny no way i see many uh
the vast majority of my male
counterparts of all parties are
courteous respectful and supportive and
unfortunately as we see in all
workplaces there is a very small
minority for whom uh you know their
their behavior for sure but is there a
culture no okay uh thank you very much
for uh being on the program today uh
zoella braverman there thank you uh very
much lots more to come
on the take after this short break we
are live here in westminster up next
we'll be talking to labour's shadow
education secretary bridget phillipson
[Music]
this is the
jubilee pudding it's a lemon and swiss
roll amaretti trifle
[Music]
i'm hannah thomas peter and i'm skye's
climate change correspondent
the uk is a world leader in wind power
power
people
it's part of the congo basin rainforest
which is such an important ecosystem
it's known as the lungs of africa
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
she doesn't really enjoy speaking to the
press and it wasn't clear right up until
the last moment that she was going to
sit down with me i might be just very
naive but i do believe that change is
possible otherwise we wouldn't be
climate activists
[Music]
i'm conference for the last 30 years we
have known how bad it is i'm not here to
apologize i'm here to fight for the next
step
you can see just the piles and piles of
stuff these this sofas and people's
desks and children's books and you can
see inside this home here people trying
to uh
to sort out their home it's just been
devastating
i think everything's at stake the future
of our planet the future of the beauty
around us
the future
of you and me
[Music]
organized
[Music]
we support communities to grow food in
lost and unloved spaces across the city
so our main kind of driving force is to
get people growing
[Music]
[Music]
hello welcome back live to westminster
you are watching the take where we can
speak now to the shadows secretary of
state for education bridget phillipson
thank you very much for being on the
program um we've been talking about uh
the chancellor rishi sunatch a speech to
the cbi he said that the government does
stand ready to do more to help families
with the cost of living crisis what do
you want to see
well i don't quite know what he's
waiting for i mean it's all very good
and well to say that he's standing ready
but families are absolutely desperate
right now they urgently need help so
labour has said that we think the
government should bring forward a
windfall tax on oil and gas producers
who bother own admission have got more
money than they know what to do with
that will provide immediate help right
now you know i hear from pensioners
who've had to turn off the heating for
weeks now because they can't afford to
heat their homes parents going without
meals because they can't afford um to
look after their children and they're
making desperate desperate choices and
they rightly expect that in those
circumstances the government will act
immediately instead we've had you know
the government telling people various
ministers saying you know work more
hours by value goods you know a litany
of kind of excuses i think it's
insulting and out of touch and we need
action now um it's clear that you know
labour is really pushing the idea of a
windfall tax and by all accounts it is a
relatively popular policy as well but i
just wonder you know this is the biggest
cost of living crisis since records
began uh actually um inflation up nine
percent 40-year high
you know to put it into context you know
the wonderful tax in the north sea is
going to raise two billion pounds at
best labour's green new deal would cost
28 billion pounds every year you're
gonna need 14 of them just to pay for
the green new deal i mean don't need
something else in the locker not just a
windfall tax what's the big idea well
the windfall tax would provide that
immediate support to families and
pensioners right now i think it's only a
matter of time by the way until the
government finally you know concede the
inevitable and follow labour's plan but
what's what's the big idea you want an
emergency budget you're going to need
more than a windfall tax in that aren't
you what what what else was in your
locker and labour's green investment
pledge would make sure that we properly
insulate our homes we know that there
are 19 million homes across the country
that aren't properly insulated so we are
more exposed than many other nations
because of that problem we've got around
insulated homes but for example take
childcare another area where families
are facing real pressure at the moment
our youngest children at nursery but
also right around the school day or two
labour's children's recovery plan would
pump in investment to early years for
our most disadvantaged children we'd
also deliver breakfast clubs and
after-school activities that would
provide real help to families right now
and it's not money from borrowing for
the you know the the child care and the
green new deals that from borrowing so
what the government set out in their
corporate response was they allocated
money for that response for the culvert
response we would have made that
decision to prioritize support for
children and families which would have
gone towards our children's recovery
plan we all know what children have gone
through during the pandemic the
sacrifices that were made and we know
the impact it's had on their learning
but alongside that right now families
are really facing the squeeze so if they
were extra help now on child care that
would make a massive difference okay now
i just want to talk to you a little bit
about uh westminster now at conservative
mp
arrested on suspicion of rape now of
course we can't comment on the
individual cases it's very important not
to
but it does feel like there's been an
awful lot of stories from sexual
harassment claims to mps resigning for
looking at porn to the most serious
allegations of all
is there a particular problem in
westminster with this kind of behaviour
well i think it it does take you to that
conclusion given what we've seen in
recent weeks i mean i am troubled that
the whip doesn't appear to have been
withdrawn in the case that you mentioned
initially i think what we also saw more
recently that's given rise to the
by-election and wakefield was a
conservative mp i was being convicted of
very serious offences but again where
action should have been taken sooner i
think you know there is a clear
responsibility
that all of us in public life are held
to high standards but i think clearly
given what we've seen in recent weeks
there is a problem there that needs
addressing and this isn't just about the
conduct of mps of course westminster is
a workplace for thousands of people so
they have a right to feel safe what
should happen do we need to talk about
closing bars for example what should
happen
i i i don't think that's the issue i
think it comes to really
a fundamental issue around power in our
society you know parliament reflects
some of the wider problems we see in
society around sexism and misogyny that
need to be tackled and yes there are
changes i think that still could be made
around the standard system in parliament
but actually what does that mean though
like what kind of change should happen
well i think there have been you know i
was involved in some of that as part of
the standards committee we have made
improvements but i think we need people
to feel confident in coming forward
where they have concerns about conduct
because as i say
westminster isn't just about mps
actually there are thousands of people
who work there and they like everyone
else have got the right to be in a safe
workplace uh just to show you this uh
tweet uh quickly i think i can do
on
i'm gonna whiz around this way instead
here we go right michael fabricant uh
the concerto mp i i'm expecting a strong
turnout of conservative mps at prime
minister's questions today not only to
demonstrate their strong support for
boris but also to prove they are not the
one told by the chief whip to stay at
home i'll be there and then a little uh
emoji as well and
is this a fair enough tweet or do you
think that it's in bad taste what's your
take on this i think it's an appalling
taste he seems to think it's funny but
i'm afraid you know serious sexual
offences aren't a laughing matter it's
just completely unacceptable i don't
know what he's thinking okay okay so
yeah you're not happy at all with the
that tweet there now just finally while
i've got you i have to ask you
kirsten of course is being investigated
by the police over allegations he denies
the allegations but he has been invested
by police over allegations that he broke
covered rules he said if he's found
guilty
he would resign
if that happens would you run
well there won't be a vacancy so that's
not going to come up that's not that
that is not an eventuality that's going
to happen i'm confident
i know it's not no well there isn't a
contest i look forward to seeing kia
starmer as the next labour prime
minister in downing street and i think
we've got a really strong prospect at
the next election given the progress
we've made in the local elections and
making that happen that's all i'm
interested in but if the ball were to
come loose at the back of the scrum as
someone once said would you pick it up
that's not going to happen there's no
vacancy i mean key has done nothing
wrong i'm confident that will be the
outcome when he's being investigated by
the police and he has said that he would
resign if he found guilty to be fair so
you know it's not completely
a question from nowhere no it's also
been clear he's done nothing wrong i'm
confident he hasn't uh he's a man who
believes very strongly in following the
rules that are set um i look forward to
kiera as the next favorite prime
minister okay thank you very much for
being on the programme today bridget
ellison you're watching the take we are
live in westminster up next we're going
to be hearing our question of the week
from pmq's
to find out what are the best bits of
the promises questions session
[Music]
[Music]
we support communities to grow food in
lost and unloved spaces across the city
so our main kind of driving force is to
get people growing
[Music]
[Music]
hello welcome back you're live in
westminster you are watching the take
now if you are a political junkie like
me it is the political highlight of
midweek prime minister's questions when
the pm faces party leaders and
backbenchers from all sides
let's have a little listen now to what
our very own joe pike political
correspondent made of it this is pmq's
unwrapped
partygate is no longer secure ground for
kiestarma's questions after allegations
about his own pandemic conduct so the
labour leader ditched that favorite
topic for this one
when would he stop the hokey kokee and
just back labour's plan for a windfall
tax to cut household bills still
pretending the economy is booming still
got his head in the sand in the middle
of an economic crisis
and secure didn't just attack the pm but
the man sitting next to him too rishi
sunak is under pressure to act but it
was striking how little he prompted the
pm today and his subdued demeanor was
reflected across the chamber it is
rarely quite so quiet
if you speak to team stammer they are
convinced a u-turn is coming on a
windfall tax on oil and gas profits one
senior figure told me it will happen
unless the government are quotes
literally mad and if and when it does
labour want to make sure voters remember
it's been their policy their position
for months now the pm blamed global
factors and he did seem skeptical of a
windfall tax but he did not rule it out
we will look at all the measures that we
need to take mr speaker to get people
through to the other side mr johnson
also went on the attack on tax
the labour's plans are always and
everywhere to raise taxes on business
his answer in addition to putting up
taxes his answer is to borrow him on
their lust to raise taxes on business
mrs dicker
we don't relish it
we don't want to do it even though of
course his government has raised taxes
to their highest level since world war
ii sky news analysis of the labour
leaders language today shows his key
theme people who can't pay their bills
the word chancellor also appears a lot
investment and the economy feature in
boris johnson's responses
elsewhere kiestama criticized jacob
rees-mogg's crusade against civil
servants working from home
the member for north east somerset
when he's not when he's not sticking
notes on people's desks that's some
overgrown prefect
provoking a grin from the minister
when is he finally gonna the lib dems
focused on farming from caithness to
cumbria from shropshire to devon
farmers own input costs are spiraling
upwards far from a coincidence with a
by-election in rural devon coming up
and one tory mp managed to slip in a dig
about the kiestarma big eight row so
it's more than just a place to bring
friends for a social evening of beer and
takeaway curry and an even better place
to live work than bring
we now seem to have reached a tipping
point on the cost of living crisis with
a situation quite so stark the longer it
takes the government to act the bigger
the advantage for labour solutions will
of course be expensive but we do expect
the chancellor to announce something
within weeks
uh joe pike they're expecting something
from the chancellor uh within uh weeks
well a little bit later we're gonna find
out what our viewers panel made of the
announcements by rishi sunak
but first we can check in with our
deputy political editor sam coats who
has joined us again on the take
so what is your take sam you know we've
heard a bit from the chancellor this
evening we just heard from suella
braverman as well on the cost of living
and where are we up to
very good question because listening to
ella braverman the attorney general on
the cost of you didn't really get a lot
further with her i i have some empathy
maybe even a little bit of pity for
ministers coming on having to answer
questions about the cost of living
they're coming on to shows like yours
unarmed there are no answers now
richie soon at this evening said
uh that we have a responsibility to help
the most vulnerable
now i can tell you if the targeted help
is just at those at the lowest end of
society when it comes out in the wash in
july that won't cut it for the tory mps
i've been talking about tonight but
beyond that there is no plan for the
conservative party some are in favor of
winfield tax some are against a winfield
tax some want to reduce income taxes
some want to reduce uh someone to
increase benefits some think that the
problem is energy bills and inflation
others think that growth not inflation
is data there is no plan across the
conservative party we're at a tipping
point
and they've got to decide what kind of
party and what kind of policy they want
to pursue and that's probably why he's
looking a bit like this at the minute
because i think even in that speech
he was almost saying that he's you know
on the one hand he knows he knows to do
more but he's obviously got this at the
back of the mind as well about if he
does provide help he's very worried
about inflation and some of those
pressures too our best days lie ahead he
said it doesn't feel like that's the
language of now to be completely honest
um let's have a look at the polling uh
is this starting to feed through into
people's opinions of you know the
government of the chancellor what are we
looking at here well this shows a
five-point need for the labour party
which is an okay lead it probably takes
you somewhere into hung parliament
territory but you can see that the
liberal democrats uh doing well they're
cycling off a little bit of vote from
labour also challenging the
conservatives the greens will definitely
be eating into the labour vote so that
figure could be higher but it's an okay
lead let's wizard on to the next screen
and you can see over time all the way
back to when boris johnson became uh
prime minister uh really uh you've got a
small lead
for the labour party over the
conservatives you have done uh pretty
much since the turn of the year with a
healthy performance for uh for the lib
dems uh so the next slide though is the
one that really fascinates me go back to
the 2019 general election and this shows
you what people do today who voted
conservative back then
only 57 percent of people who voted tory
in the 2019 general election still would
it would be alarming
but let's look at where they should put
their votes out only seven percent
actually go all the way to the labour
party an awful lot of them say that they
just don't know and that's uh people not
willing to say they vote tory but not
willing to pick one of the other uh
parties now let's look at the situation
with the labour party now they're in
opposition they should be wildly popular
but they don't keep three in ten of
their votes only 69 percent of people
that voted labor in 2019 still do uh and
they you can see their vote bleeds all
over the place they're in opposition
they should be popular but seven percent
of their voters go lib dem six percent
of their voters go green and only eleven
uh go uh don't know which will be easier
probably to transfer back into that
labor column uh but uh that number is
smaller so in some senses tories i was
showing these two graphs um these two
charts too actually said they'd rather
be in that position they think that
number don't know it'll just flip back
to the conservatives uh at election time
they were quite relieved uh that that
number wasn't bigger i guess that the
tories are the labour party are still uh
are at even at this stage losing some of
their supporters from 2017 without uh
particularly uh seeing people vote go
all the way across from the uh
conservative party to labor in large
numbers
fascinating does feel like that's all to
playful in the kind of lots could change
because of this a big number of uh dope
nose there thank you very much sam for
your analysis as always uh coming up uh
next we are going to be talking to our
viewers panel to find out what they
think about the issue that everyone's
talking about the cost of living crisis
[Music]
we're a member of the independent foodie
network so
we speak to other food banks across the
uk there's over a thousand independent
food banks and over 1400 trustless trust
food banks across the uk
certainly the independent food banks are
really struggling to meet the demand of
people who are needing
food support and i think in terms of one
and four skipping meals i think that
would be that would ring true for a lot
of people who work in food banks and
volunteer there
and we would expect people to be doing
things like that before they even access
the food bank i think
going to a food bank is
an incredibly traumatic stressful thing
for people to do
i think it puts a lot of strain on
families and households and what we
really need to be looking at is how do
we avoid that how do we stop people ever
needing to use the food bank and the
only way we can do that is by getting
more money in people's pockets
we definitely saw a spike in october
when the universal credit uplift was
removed that was an immediate spike uh
we saw another increase in january as
the cost of living began to increase
then um and we don't see it slowing
so you know in terms of is there a point
when people can take a breath and
reassess things no it's too late for
that i think what we saw during the
pandemic was
um a case where
financial support was put in quite
quickly and an understanding that that
was possible and i think after the
pandemic or well as it's anything um you
know we were talking about what lessons
did we learn um and how can we implement
those again if a crisis occurs well a
crisis is occurring right now
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello welcome back live to westminster
you are watching the take
well it's my favorite part of the
program actually national numeracy day
today the government is keen of course
to get us brushing up on our mass but
there are some pretty grim numbers
flying around not least of course now
inflation
is now at nine percent real wages are
actually falling for most people when
you take that into account now we've
heard from the politicians uh about what
they're going to do we've heard from
russia soon act we've heard from zoella
braverman we've heard from bridget
phillipson but what do people watching
sky news make of all the arguments
between the parties over the cost of
living in crisis we can speak now to our
viewers panel hello everybody it's great
to have you uh with us now if you're
wondering why there is an empty box here
the reason is uh because unfortunately
um chloe forrest has lost her internet
connection which i think tells you quite
a lot about perhaps rural broadband she
is in cumbria in a village her internet
is down
maybe one uh for others to take up but
that is that that is life that is what
live tv is all about
now i want to talk to uh our panel about
the cost of living crisis i want to talk
to you guys
about the cost of living crisis you know
energy going up petrol going up
food going up inflation of course at a
40-year high
if you've started making changes to your
spending already because of the cost of
living crisis just put up your hand and
that could be filling up your tank a
little bit less it could be turning your
heating on less it could be
going value brands in the supermarket
put your hand up if you've already
started making changes
now that is a lot of people isn't it
that's a clear majority on our panel who
are already
making those uh changes well let's talk
to roy first on that shall we let's talk
to roy royner at your conservative photo
you're based in kent roy um talk to us
about the cost of living crisis how
concerned are you
um i am marginally concerned i the only
thing that that keeps me going is that
the fact that it's going to it's going
to come to an end so you know i've been
through several recessions i've seen it
before i've been in an
area of era of 15 um mortgage rates so
it's it's not it's not new um and things
will turn around that's why it's called
a cycle um you know economics is just a
cycle so i'm i'm not overly concerned as
to the length of it because i you know
you can see where it stemmed from you
know from china gets switched up
you were saying as well what you were
pleased at promises questions to hear
the politicians actually talking about
the cost of living crisis as well
weren't you
absolutely let's get back to real
matters not not not some the latest gate
as it were so i'm i'm yeah i i am
pleased that they they they're
concentrating on real issues at the
moment and not not um
uh obsessing on who's crossing or on
crossing their legs or who's drinking
beer or wine or whatever okay uh thanks
very much for your take always good uh
to talk roy uh let's bring in uh ros
mcmullen now at shall we a labor voter
uh you're based in york uh like roy
we've we've chat to you before on the
take haven't we so i'm keen to hear your
views on prime minister's questions
today what did you make of it
well i think we had the situation where
we had a grown-up
asking some serious questions
and a very very embarrassing prime
minister who was obfuscating
deflecting and lying
and you know at one stage he even seemed
to imply that agreeing to a windfall tax
was giving in to putin and that but
where where on earth has that come from
constantly harping on about having a
strong economy
when in fact our economy is the slowest
growing at the moment i mean
it's just nonsense kirsten's questions
were not answered
and he just continued to deflect blame
obfuscate lie
he's an embarrassment it really is
embarrassing now not a fan of boris
johnson are pretty clear there let's
talk to lucy shower this is lucia tala
you're based in swansea and you uh lucy
a labour voter as well and what did you
make of kierstama do you think that he
did a good performance at prime
minister's questions
um not too bad i thought his comment
about an overgrown prefect was really
good i want that to stick so i'm going
to make it my mission to say it as much
as possible so that people keep saying
it too because i i do feel as if there
is a bit of a culture of you know eating
boys and prefects and sort of head boy
getting the privileges and it's you know
so i found that quite amusing
um in terms of
uh
i never feel he he fights hard enough i
always feel as if he's a little bit kind
of
weak in his responses i prefer him to be
a bit more assertive
but he wasn't too bad okay interesting
so not too bad bit more assertive that's
your verdict uh there well let's talk to
john now shall we john commerford uh
you're a conservative voter you're from
kent i'm quite interested to hear that
um you know you've always voted
conservative haven't you but now
is it right to say that you're actually
thinking about not voting at all for the
first time what why is that
i'm just a little bit disillusioned at
the moment um
although i have to say a little bit
encouraged this evening
that the chancellor is finally
recognising there is a problem but he
needs to deal with the problem now not
in three four months time or whatever
um i don't think the government have
been helped consider
greatly by
certain ministers going on tv and make
them very unhelpful comments i thought
the comments by
george eustis and
rachel mclean in the last 10 days or so
absolutely appalling
i don't think they recognize that people
are suffering
and that doesn't just apply to
vulnerable people it applies also
to many people are working very hard
very long hours to free jobs
and they're struggling to either heat
their houses or
alternatively put food on the table it's
just not good enough and that needs to
be addressed it does feel like we're
getting quite a lot of consensus on that
and let's bring in uh andrew fairley at
farley shall we and do you agree with
some of what um our panelists were just
saying there about everyone being
impacted by the cost of living crisis
absolutely i think
it's
it's it really is
going to be
um the next crisis from from following
on from the pandemic and and it seems as
though
you listen to the responses uh this
this afternoon from from boris johnson
and he doesn't seem to
know what to do or or whether he's going
to make up his mind on a windfall tax i
think that's that's just to start a bit
of windfall tax if it's only going to
raise 2 billion then that's just the
start of it that should that should be
an absolute given uh
the government have been uh
benefiting from all of these higher
prices which means extra tax receipts
which the chancellor is trying to use um
in two years time for her uh for a nice
sleight of hand uh attack cut for
everybody before the election
any
all of these extra tax receipts he's got
to use them now to help people i'm going
to have to jump in now because i do want
to get to our last two uh panelists and
some really interesting thoughts so far
belinda campbell you're based in
twickenham south west london
describe yourself as a swing voter who
do you think won at pmq's today
i think kier starmer did win because he
made he just kept repeating himself and
putting his point across and i was
listening to the background um responses
as well
and you know not everybody is i don't
think it's inclusive if you just talk
about very very poor people i don't
think that's including a lot of other
people in certain situations which are
different thanks for your uh take i'm
just gonna squeeze colin in at the end
colin very very quickly because i might
have to crash out we're running out of
time on the program who do you think you
want at pmq's today
uh definitely cursed alma
i believe kirsten was the winner uh he
asked really good questions i don't
think boris johnson had any answers
today
well i have to say it was a pretty uh
you unanimous for once uh panel it feels
like there's some real concerns about uh
cost of living uh even our sort of
conservative voters glad that we were uh
talking about that as well so thank you
very much colin we'll have more from you
on another program i'm absolutely sure
we promised that's a promise from me
that's it from the take we will be back
next week and every week on wednesdays
at 9 00 pm
next up it is sky news at 10. thank you
for watching
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
the inspiration behind our product came
from understanding how big of a problem
livestock meat and emissions were
i'm ivan bonio i'm a sailor
i spent
half time of my life on the on the sea
we have a factory we can convert this
plastic to energy
and so after at the end we can minimize
the footprint carbon of the boat
[Music]
so
[Music]
you